when you think about what the field of
economics is about it is quite daunting
an economy is made up of millions or
even billions of actors organized in
incredibly complex ways right then this
is complex real world and each of the
actors human beings or organizations
these are incredibly complex a human
brain I can't predict what you're going
to do the next second much less what
you're going to do the next day or the
next year and imagine trying to make
insights about what millions or billions
of people will do but the field of
economics has borrowed an idea from
other fields so for example in chemistry
chemists have tried to understand at a
high level well how do molecules in a
container behave let's say molecules of
gas well you could imagine if you have a
container here with trillions upon
trillions of molecules this is
incredibly complex but by making some
simplifying assumptions
about the type of interactions these
particles will have or don't have they
can come up with models like the ideal
gas law which you might be familiar with
or not from your chemistry class that
relates the pressure to the volume to
the number of particles you have to the
actual temperature and so this right
over here where you're taking something
that's hairy and complex and making
simplifying assumptions to help you
understand it this thing right over here
is a model and this is in other fields
as well sometimes it's not an equation
sometimes it might be a simpler organism
for example in biology human beings are
incredibly complex organisms and not
only are they incredibly complex but
certain forms of experimentation would
also feel fairly unethical to our modern
moral ethos and so what do biologists do
well they make simplifying assumptions
or they pair down they say okay we can't
do that study on human beings but maybe
we can simplify the problem by looking
at simpler organisms maybe you can look
at an individual cell right over here
maybe you can look at things like fruit
flies which are famous in their study in
the study of genetics maybe you can even
look at fairly complex organisms even a
mouse is a very complex thing but it's
still simpler than a human being and at
least to our modern ethics we're willing
to do certain things to mice that we
aren't willing to do to human beings and
so that's why in a biological context
you will hear people talk about things
like a mouse model where they will test
the drug on a mouse or try to understand
how something happens in a mouse and
then say well that's pretty good
indication that might be happening to
human beings in fact when they do drug
trials in medicine they often will do it
on mice first and when they have good
confidence that it works there and that
it's fairly safe only then will they
start to do the experiments on human
beings
well economists are doing the same thing
even before the advent of computers and
models economists make simplifying
assumptions
assumptions like all of the actors in an
economy are rational which we already
know is not exactly true I'm not always
rational and I definitely know people
who aren't always rational
they're simplifying assumptions that all
of the people in an economy have the
same access to information or that they
all even have perfect information which
we also know isn't necessarily true in a
real economy so depending on the model
there going to be these simplifying
assumptions that take this large complex
real world thing and try to break it
down into simple equations or lines or
charts we have models early on in our
economic study we will see things like
the production possibility frontier
where it assumes that you're only
trading off between two things and
everything else is equal this notion of
ceteris ceteris paribus which means all
things equal in a real world you're not
going to be able to say hey let's just
pick between these two things and then
hold everything else equal there's
hundreds or thousands or millions of
variables are operating but if you want
to make a model maybe we can make these
assumptions same thing with famous price
equilibria that we're going to study
later on where you have supply and
demand and then you have these notions
of equilibrium prices and quantities
these also make similar types of
assumptions about rational actors and
perfect information and these economic
models can be very useful and that's why
most of your study in a first-year
economics course is of these models now
with that said you should also take them
with a grain of salt and you shouldn't
just accept them as the absolute
description of reality in fact that's
when economic models can get dangerous
you always have to be conscientious of
what are those assumptions you made in
fact Nobel Prizes have been won in
economics by revisiting some simplifying
assumptions and coming up with new
models the other difficulty about
economics is it's hard to test it in as
absolute a way definitely as something
like chemistry or physics but even in
biology where you're dealing with
similarly complex
the human body and an economy these are
both extremely complex systems if I want
to see in medicine whether a certain
medication works I can do a clinical
trial I could take hundreds or thousands
of people and give maybe half of them
the drug and I could try to control for
a bunch of different variables but in
economics
you can't take a thousand different
economies that look very similar in what
you think matters and then apply some
type of economic prescription to half of
them and then see what happens to see
whether your model is exactly true or
whether your prescription for what makes
an economy grow faster actually work and
so the big takeaway models are valuable
across the various Sciences including in
economics but economics straddles
between the social science and the
sciences like chemistry or physics
because you can't run experiments in the
same way and we often make simplifying
assumptions that even though we know
aren't exactly true they're the only way
that we're able to make sense of an
incredibly complex real world